[Music]
joining the Kardashian Moms Club
loi foreshadowed the news and the June
Keeping Up with the Kardashians finale
Tristan and I definitely talked about
starting a family but now like knowing
I'm not on birth control that's just
like it's scary it's like a really big
step a source close to Chloe tells us
she is expecting her first child early
next year with her boyfriend of over a
year Cleveland Cavaliers player Tristan
Thompson which makes three pregnancies
right now for the sisters its kilt Ichi
previously confirmed 20 year old Kylie
is having a baby girl with her boyfriend
rapper Travis Scott Kim and Kanye are
expecting their third baby also a girl
via a surrogate everybody started to
celebrate TVland doesn't know the time
see the drink at anytime
while Chloe was happily sipping
champagne a pregnancy nono during ease
ten-year anniversary special et has
learned the show was actually taped in
April before the pregnancy then on June
the 25th two weeks after the season
finale Chloe gave a huge clue about the
baby news
she snapchat in this shot with the
caption quote dad and mom and if history
is to be repeated we predict all three
sisters will confirm the news themselves
at the end of Sunday's season 14
premiere after all that's what they did
for seasons 9 and 10 this season on
Keeping Up with the Kardashians I am
pregnant and I am
[Music]
you
[Music]